a hidden keep elite not-taken  retrace your steps escape your past and  the key will be yours at last what part  of your past are you trying to escape  valide  [Music]  this is the Oasis a whole virtual  universe you can do anything be anyone  without going anywhere at all the Oasis  was created by James Halliday  and what he left behind changed  everything a contest three impossible  challenges the first to finish gets  complete control of the Oasis which  means complete control of the future  contest is not a peep about connecting  with someone connecting you to the world  [Music]  so we take it together sure  [Music]  [Music]  save the Oasis save the ball there  are you ready  [Music]  I'll wave to you from the finish line  McFly that will will  you